what am i doing what am i doing corn
corn corn hey guys it's katie and i'm
here with my husband chris
hi and today i am going to try to make
the chili's
baby back rib platter faster than
delivery
my delivery man boy is gonna be chris
i'm the delivery man boy
the rip platter consists of baby rack
ribs fries
and roasted street corn that sounds
really good that's a lot to do
and i think probably about an hour
that's crazy
you're gonna do great ready to order are
you ready to put that order in
no but let's do it let's do it let's put
the order in new cart
view card click view cart my name is
chris
chris placing the order and
it's still loading because my phone is
slow ah go
oh it's done whoa i've never been so
scared about it
so the first thing i need to do is prep
a dry rub for the rib
so i'm gonna do some coarse salt pepper
chili powder cayenne gonna be a little
spicy
garlic powder onion powder a little bit
of sugar a little bit of white
pepper mix that right up so now i have
my baby back ribs
nice and i'm gonna cut them in half so
i'm just taking the dry rub and
sprinkling it all over the top
i don't have enough time i don't have
time i don't have time i don't have time
okay
i think that looks good let me go wash
my hands i'll be right back
[Music]
so i don't have enough time to make
these ribs in the oven or
on a grill so what i'm gonna do is use
my instant pot i am
so lucky that i have it
song take this rack out that i have i'm
gonna add
some water liquid smoke apple cider
vinegar
this is actually going to help tenderize
the meat as it cooks in here
we're going to add our rack back and
then we're just going to place our ribs
inside got to wash my hands we'll place
the top on
seal the vent pressure cook this for 25
minutes
in a red light that's good for katie
i'm already out of breath it's
terrifying i'll take our corn we'll put
it in the cast iron skillet
and then i'm going to just drizzle it
with a little bit of olive oil
we'll add some salt for seasoning make
sure you get the seasoning on all the
sides i'm going to go place this
uncovered in the oven for about 15 to 20
minutes
while that's in the oven i'm going to
make the mayo sauce that will brush on
it at the very end
just so it's out of the way so i've got
some sour cream i'm gonna add a little
bit of mayonnaise to that
and squeeze some fresh lime juice season
with a little bit of salt
and mix this together i'm gonna set it
off to the side and we're gonna start
on the fries let's do it oh my god i
forgot i forgot chili powder
in this okay so that's the mixture so
glad we remembered that
let's move on to the fries for real
about a mile away
almost there okay i've got everything i
need for the fries
just an update the instant pot is
finally at pressure and we've got 24
minutes on it
i haven't heard from chris yet so that's
good right i am
here the chili sign is right there oh my
god i'm parked
i thought it's only fair that i make
these fries from scratch first thing i
gotta do
peel a potato my peeler isn't that sharp
thank you so much you have a good one no
no
no no hello hey
so no no no no no no no no
uh it's it is happening i have you on
speakerphone here in the car so the ribs
can hear you
just drive slow
i don't even tell you where i'm at i'm
gonna be there soon though so
okay i have to go i love you i love you
too i'm so scared okay bye
ah okay uh gotta peel this potato a lot
faster
oh my god maybe this was never doable
how could i have thought this was doable
just i okay wow
all right let me uh let me cut this
potato up here i'm gonna cut a little
bit
off the bottom and then i'm going to cut
him in
two slices stack them here
we go okay what do i need what do i need
i need tongue
for this special occasion tasty got me a
thermometer gun so i can quickly take
the temperature of something so
we need to be at 300 and i'm at 295.
i'm at almost 300 so we're just gonna go
in
whoop i'm trying to do a shallow fry so
that our oil didn't take too long to
heat up
and it's a little crowded that's all
right and i'm just gonna let these go
for about four minutes
where the first batch of fries is going
i'm gonna make our barbecue sauce that
we're gonna brush on top of the baby
back ribs
i'm gonna hack a barbecue sauce because
i don't have time to make it from
scratch
so i've got a brown sugar barbecue sauce
chipotle and adobo sauce
and chili powder and the last thing i'll
add is a splash of
orange juice and that'll just give it a
nice tang i'm going to set it off to the
side
and we'll get our batch of fries out of
here
turning on the freeway oh yep they feel
tender
and they've got a slight color to them
so i'm going to take them out let's see
if i can speed this up with a fork
oh they're coming apart don't do that
maybe it's just
nope i need something else yes i'm not
moving fast now i've got to get the heat
up to 375.
i'm gonna season our potatoes with some
salt something's happening in the oven
i'll be right back
i think our corn may be close to done
it's gonna give it a couple more
minutes let's check the time on temp on
this let's get these bad boys
back in careful
gently get this out of here what am i
doing what am i doing what am i doing
what am i doing corn corn corn
i just got the corn out and i put my
oven to broil because we're gonna have
to broil those as soon as they come out
i'm gonna brush this with our mayo thing
right now
chris chris is probably just having a
great time
fries fry faster i'm going to brush him
with a little bit more mayo sprinkle a
little cotija
and then my favorite cilantro let me put
him here
the inside pot is done the instant pot
is ready
our fries look almost done i'm gonna
start to take them out and now they're
crispy enough that i can use my tongs
last thing we'll do is season them with
some more salt and then i have some
freshly ground pepper here fries are
done fries are done
we're within four exits of
our apartment so katie is running out of
time she's got about
by my calculation five minutes until i'm
there
okay ribs coming out coming out
oh looks good
where's the barbecue sauce there's the
barbecue sauce oh my god i might i might
be able to do this he's not here yet
oh my gosh okay all right i'm gonna go
put them in the oven to broil
and hopefully it's going to give them a
nice crispy top okay thank you
everything's okay
his park is that his car
no no i'm no um yep okay
here i know you're here chris is here
it's fine guess what just came
ah it's hot wait let me plate it
no no no i cannot believe it
the beef just went off as soon as you
opened the door this looked fabulous you
did an amazing job
oh my god okay oh my god i cannot
believe it was like
it was like a tie i mean yeah okay it
was a tie
let's see who wins with taste let's put
these side by side okay
i i think they look amazing their corn
obviously gets more char
mine did not get as much color but my
fries i think look a little bit more
crispy than theirs
that's the thing i think your fries do
look like they have a little more crisp
on them so
i like them let's try chili's first
it's sweet savory let's try yours
yours are tender and crispy it's really
good let's try their fries
nice it's good so let's try mine
i like how crispy mine are i would give
your fries the egg
all right last thing we have to try is
the corn nice flavor
packs a cilantro punch okay let's try
yours is really really good but
there's the char i think takes it over
the top they win on the corn so i went
on the ribs and i run on the fries but
chili wins on the corn
that's right you can't win them all but
you can win two out of three
katie this was awesome yeah this is so
fun i love ribs
and i love you oh yes
you